a henderson doggie daycare revoking  its license dakota's doggie den runs out  of this home near u.s 95  and college last night animal control  officers showed up to find  51 dogs inside that home the city issued  a citation against the owner for having  too many dogs  we spoke to that owner who says she's  been working closely with this city  to make sure she's following the rules  it's the same officer that gave me that  information yesterday and told me  i had this and they weren't explaining  to me why  what changed they didn't say anything as  to why anything changed  why they were telling me something why  they were pulling my license today  half of the dogs were returned to their  owners the rest taken to the henderson  shelter where they can be picked up free  of charge  we will continue to stay on top of this  story trying to learn more about exactly  what happened between this business  and the city